Welcome to another Zoom call.
Hope everybody has a wonderful Thanksgiving plan with their families.
Just to remind her please ask your questions on the members site.
And let's jump into the questions.
I switched my curcumin to alternating between the terriba and the liposomal curcumin liquid.
You've recommended around 4,000 milligrams daily of curcumin.
But is the dosage different for the liposomal liquid?
One teaspoon equals 200 milligrams.
So yes, whatever you're taking anything liposomal you could expect about, you know, you could take the dosage and times it by about five.
So if you're trying to get 4,000 milligrams, you're still going to need that's the negative about the liposomal is that it's expensive.
So it's expensive because you really get on average about five times the absorption of a capsule.
So if you're trying to get 4,000 and you get, you're getting 1,000 milligrams per teaspoon, you really still need four teaspoons of it.
You can do that math out there that would help.
You get, if you can think of about five X as the, as the calculating factor for the difference between liposom and a capsule for that is about five X.
So, so take the liposomal times five.
So that's really the absorption benefit absorption rate.
I just came across this sales pitch for store based probiotics.
Their claim was that regular probiotics are 99% destroyed by your stomach acid and never reach your smaller test and to do anything for you.
The compounds that are store based do survive stomach acid and go on to do their work. Have you ever heard of this? Is this a real thing?
So there's, there are benefits to store based probiotics for several reasons.
But does survive stomach acid better that figure that 99% of other probiotics are destroyed in the stomach acid is, is it correct?
So that is wrong sales pitch claim right there.
I don't think you need, everybody needs four base probiotics.
Better fact, good companies that are selling probiotics that have store base and nuns, for base probiotics.
Typically recommend because the research recommends that you don't need to be on store base probiotics indefinitely.
If you're taking a probiotic daily, you might want to take store base.
This is why my whole idea is to alternate your probiotics so that you're changing even companies that you're getting them from.
So that you're getting different varieties, grown different and different batches and it can have benefits that way.
So I think store by base probiotics are great. We use all the molecular store based probiotics. We use mega store, store based probiotics.
They are more stable. They are more expensive though.
You don't need to take store based probiotics on a regular basis.
Maybe go through a model store based probiotics then switch to a different non store based probiotic then switch to a different probiotic.
That's why we have multiple different probiotics on our store and I have said over and over again that I think there's benefit to rotating your probiotics.
Have you heard of the higher dose brand of infrared soda blankets and infrared PFF bands?
If so, what is your opinion of them and do they help with cancer?
I wondered also the difference between the infrared heating pad. You have on your website for $160 and the one for $198 to either of these help reduce tumors.
And with any of these options serve the same function as going into an infrared sonner trying to determine the most economic way to address the cancer with infrared.
Okay, so do you get benefit from the infrared heating infrared heat pad for cancer?
No, so the only purpose for you to use an infrared heating pad would be for the source for a heat source, not for an infrared source.
You're using the heating pad to heat and give you some deep heat for the purpose of, you know, if you have a cold or you have pneumonia or if you have an infection heat can be real beneficial.
So that we're talking about a heating pad right now. And or I highly recommend using the heating pads over your liver over your gallbladder.
It could help decrease the viscosity of your bile. It could help move things through your liver. So there's huge benefits to the heating pads.
Now, what heating pads should I use? I just use an electric heating pad that my mom used to have would when I was little, no, because those have just heating coils in it can cause EMF issues are not really good for you.
Well, then what's a good heating patch? I just use one of those microwaveable packs that, you know, you know that you microwave for three minutes said, well, those are really nice.
But they don't hold their heat for very long. So not a very much of a fan of those except maybe on the goal or something like that.
Then what should you use hot water bottle? You can too, but the hot water gets cool and get it doesn't hold its heat very long.
That's why I like those infrared heating pads. They don't have the electric coils in them that are going to cause any EMF issues.
But let's be honest, they're not really putting out much in for a random. So there's really not much in for a red benefit to them.
So, but it's a better source of heat. So which one should you use it? We have two of them. One that's a little cheaper than the other. Actually, I personally use the one that's a little cheaper.
That's the one we have at home. That's the one we have at the office.
That's, you know, we've given that to our kids for Christmas presents. I think they're great little units. I really like those units you, I would, I would go with the least lesser expensive infrared heating pad.
Up to the top question again, if you heard of the higher dose brand of infrared sauna blankets and the infrared key MF pads. I don't think they're worth their money. And they're certainly not something that's quote unquote cancer, I would not spend my money on those.
The bottom paragraph. Would any of these be options that serve the same function as the infrared sauna. Don't not at all. The purpose of the infrared sauna again is not to give you infrared waves. You're getting very little true infrared from an infrared sauna. The purpose of an infrared sauna is to cook you is to make you sweat is to help you detoxify
and bypass the liver and the kidney help you to use the organ of your skin as a detoxification pathway. That's the purpose of an infrared sauna. They are not in this it's not even in the same category as the first two paragraphs.
Again, all the purpose of infrared heat pad is to produce heat over a specific area. The purpose of an infrared sauna is to make you sweat.
So if finances are an issue like don't have a thousand dollars to spend in a sauna, just get a heat pad. Let's get the infrared heat pad. Don't spend the money on that infrared key MF bands.
If you thought I would benefit from Ivermectin against breast cancer when you did the cheek swab or even the genetic analysis could you have suggested I asked my doctor about it.
I can't test for that because it is a prescription medication whereas versus bed dissolves and over the counter medication.
So I can't test for that. So I can't do that. But I've said over and over. I think there's any downside of taking in for taking Ivermectin.
No, I really don't see a big downside in taking Ivermectin.
Because you could argue well could it throw off your gut flora your microbiota possibly that would be the only downside it would not throw off your gut flora like taking it at a biotic one.
So I don't see any downside. If you're doing well on your current protocol, I guess I wouldn't add it. But if I was in a situation where I feel like a kind of slippy or going a little bit downhill, I would consider adding it, especially if you, you know, are
you feel really led in that way. So follow, finish up the question.
My GP is cooperative and will help. I suppose that means in prescribing it. I'm already on a parasite cleanse protocol. So the benefit of Ivermectin and cancer really isn't the parasitic anti parasitic effect of the Ivermectin.
Ivermectin, it is, it's basically an off label effect meeting. It's not that it's killing parasites.
And therefore benefiting somebody with cancer because they have parasites. It's working on a different metabolic pathway.
So, oh, does the bed is all work for some people with cancer because their cancer is caused by parasitic worms because bed is all is a, is a medication for parasitic worms.
So is that the reason why it helps with some people with cancer because their cancer is caused for parasitic worms, that at all, that at all.
It's, it's, it's, it's working on a different metabolic pathway that's slowly the growth of cancer has nothing to do with. It's, it's benefit to help kill words. So same thing with Ivermectin, it's working on a completely different path.
I don't know if this person means C-E-A or what they're meeting, they're C-A, something, and they're C-A-15, I think they may be the C-A-15-3.
Triple, these are two remarkers, tripled in six weeks, any suggestions.
Yes, we should have a conversation, we should do another cheek swab, we should at least have a conversation next week.
But you see your two remarkers, you know, go up a few points or go down a few points, you shouldn't really get too excited.
It's just one marker, and that can change, just things are going. But if it triples, then that's a concern. Now, when is it not a concern if the two marker goes jumps really high?
It's not a concern if the person is doing chemotherapy.
So if the person is doing chemotherapy, that can cause ISIS, and that can cause a person's tumor markers, if you're doing tumor marker tests, it doesn't always, but it can cause the tumor markers just to triple or quadruple or go up ten times.
So if the person who asked this question is doing chemotherapy, then I don't set up a time to talk to me.
But if not, then we should talk, we should probably talk after you get your bone scan and CT results back.
We still have a kidney-paid sense, COVID is not sure which way to turn. Let's wait till we get your bone scan, your CT scan. So we have more objective data to go at and be able to answer that question.
Did I miss the question about iron supplementation?
No, because we didn't have a question about iron supplementation.
This time, none came in.
You actually, we actually addressed, I think you're talking about this question here.
We addressed this on a Monday Zoom call, but I'll talk about it again right now.
She will go and tested today at 7.9, and I'm scheduled for surgery in three weeks.
They want to bring up my human global, but either with a blood transfusion or supplementation, I know cancer cells can feed on iron.
What would we recommend?
I would recommend, if your human goal is 7.9, there's the fastest way to raise human global is a blood transfusion.
There's just that is, that is, there's just no substitute for that.
So I would recommend that, that will raise it up. That would because you're getting the influx of blood, you're not really feeding the cancer with that either.
And yes, iron can feed cancer. If your hemoglobin was at a point where they would not give you a blood transfusion, let's say it's 8.3 and their cutoff is 8.0.
Different hospitals, different clinics have different cutoffs.
So if they are willing to give you a blood transfusion, I would definitely go with that.
So it's going to raise your, your hemoglobin, most rapidly, you'll feel a lot better, you'll be prepped for the surgery.
Remember, if you do ask a question before noon on Monday, most likely it's going to be a Monday Zoom call. So sorry about that.
I submitted questions right before the Zoom call starting.
Yes, you did.
Yes, you did. I didn't care. You were talking like four minutes before the Zoom call started.
Okay, so let's see if I can get those.
So here's why are some cancers fast growing.
And some cancers slow growing.
So the speed of replication is the speed of the growth of the cancer.
And why is that?
Good question. There's multiple different metabolic factors that are taking place with a cancer.
And it really has to do with how whatever, you know, is causing the cancer, whatever caused the cancer, whatever damage the DNA in the first place.
And what rate that, that replication is taking place.
And that can change through a person's cancer.
That does change constantly because as you go through some treatment, it slows the cancer growth.
And then the cancer can take off again. And then you do something different.
It can slow the cancer growth so that it can take off again.
So that rate of replication changes.
And there's just multiple factors that affect the close, you have to tie in the rate of apoptosis at the same time, because if you can be killing the cancer that faster than it's replicating, then you're going to be winning your battle.
And my slow growing cancer suddenly or gradually, we just answered that question that can change on a regular basis.
And it can be because the cancer found a new fuel source.
It can be because your immune system was compromised.
So we have seen with this vaccine that's out, that cancers have taken off, not just with people that were vaccinated.
But if you're around people that are vaccinated and you end up with, with sloughing, um, um, vaccine particles and spike proteins.
It's just, you can't argue that fact, though, that it's suppressed by the medical establishment and suppressed by the media.
The vaccine is caused cancers to literally just explode.
And we've seen it here in our little TV media clinic, and it is definitely nationwide.
It's actually changed, um, the death, um, statistics on a lot of people that have passed away with cancer.
And they've labeled them as passing away with the co-borbidity.
So let's comment with, you know, let's say lung cancer person passes away with stage 4 lung cancer, they list them as pneumonia death in order so that they skew the statistics.
I know that sounds very construed story, but it's just true.
Um, that's just one aspect that can increase the goal to the cancer stress is another thing.
So you have an increase about a stress in your life, something drastic has happened in your relationships or in your family and your stress goes way up.
And as you hear this quite often, then a person's cancer just starts going crazy again.
So there's all sorts of things. Why does stress do that because stress is a stimulant of your sympathetic nervous system.
That's why we encourage you guys to stay doing coffee in a bus because that's going to stimulate your parasympathetics.
Look at that, um, the forms that I have on the website and I have it on the, um,
that ever site on different, those different functional medicine functional neurology exercises to stimulate your parasympathetics and become your sympathetic.
Those are really important. They're silly, but they're important to they actually work.
So don't discount doing those kind of things.
Your parasympathetic nervous system is your neurological control of all your detoxification pathways as well as neurological control of your immune system.
So the more you could do to stimulate your parasympathetics and to suppress or comb your sympathetic told the better you're going to be.
I did not do a bestectomy state unhoxy and hoxy got rid of the cancer with the cancer likely re occur by having cosmetic fat transfer to fill in the shrunken breast.
That's the question that absolutely is unanswerable.
So nobody goes to it, you know, there's no way I could answer that.
Is your risk greater by having that done.
So there's lots of women that have had reconstructive surgery years later, they're just fine.
So if you got to just, you got to just be prayed about that again. That's what you want to do. That's what's going to make you feel better about yourself. Those are really important too. That's a parasympathetic stimulation.
So, you know, don't feel bad because you want to do something that's going to make you feel better on yourself too. So, you don't let anybody make you feel guilty about that.
And your last question.
Is DIP lap or lipo fat transfer surgery or cosmetic reasons less invasive than that's to be a reconstruction.
I'm not a surgeon, so I don't know all the surgical ins and outs of these types of a cosmetic surgery. So you'd have to really ask them.
I don't have an answer for that. I do apologize. I don't know all the surgeries that are available for people. So I wish I could help you with that, but I don't know which one is more invasive.
And what effect you more, I would think that just thinking of what's taking place in the surgery, the best activity and reconstruction is probably more invasive.
So that you can get a better answer from your surgeon.
Any other questions.
Hope everybody has a great Thanksgiving plan.
Family coming over and enjoying family.
It's a very binder to just be thankful, isn't it? So let's work on that. All of us need to just be more grateful.
Even in difficult times, the more grateful we can be, why do we want to do that? Is it something mysterious or magical?
For the neurological standpoint, honestly, it's a stimulant of your parisabetics.
Great from this. Thank you for this. Thank you.
Turn off the news. There you go. That's the best thing you could do.
Turn off the television.
How's Ann Sun doing? She was in a big meeting with, well, the colleges today. We haven't heard anything.
She is doing, she's doing well. So that's very good news. So thank you for asking.
Thank you. Have you ever wonderful Thanksgiving? All of you as well. Please keep an eye on Sun with your prayers.
Know that we are praying for all of you every day.
And just wish that you all have this wonderful Thanksgiving with your family.
And we will not be in the office on Friday.
I may run into some orders so you have orders coming in.
Please go ahead and do that.
Alright, everybody, be blessed. Be blessed and I love you all. I'll talk to you guys next week.